WE'RE BACK IN TALKING WITH
THE FIRST MINISTER OF
SCOTLAND, NICOLA STUGON.
NOW DAVID CAMERON IS THE
HEAD OF THE CONSERVATIVE
PARTY.
YOU HAVE BROUGHT, FIRST OF
ALL, DEMOLISHED LABOUR
ED MILLI BAND AND THE LABOUR
PARTY, ARE THEY ANGRY AT SNP OR
ARE THEY MORE DISAPPOINTED
IN SNP AND MILLIBAND.
DID YOU OUTFLANK THEM?
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> WELL, THEY'RE
DISAPPOINTED IN MILLIBAND,
BUT THEY ARE EXPRESSING THAT
BY AT THE SNP IT IS EASIER
TO BLAME THE SNP THAT WE GOT
DEMOLISHED IN THE ELECTION THAN
TO SPEAK UP FOR THE REASONS WHY
THEY GOT DEMOLISHED.
WHAT DOES THE SNP DO TO BEAT
LABOR SO COMPREHENSIVELY, WE
STARTED ACTING MORE LIKE
PEOPLE EXPECT THE LABOUR
PARTY TO ASK.
WE STOOD UP AGAINST AUSTERITY.
WE SAID, YOU KNOW, WAHAT?
DON'T WANT TO SPEND $100 BILLION
ON NEW TRIDENT NUCLEAR
MISSILES.
WE'D RATHER DO SOMETHING RADICAL
AND INVEST THAT IN HEALTHCARE,
IN EDUCATION, IN GIVING KIDS
THE BEST START IN LIFE.
YOU HAVE TO GO BACK 10 OR 20
YEARS, THESE ARE THE THINGS
LABOROUR POLITICIANS USED TO
SAY IN THE U.K., BUT NOT ANY
MORE.
THEY OUT RIGHT-WING THE
CONSERVATIVES, AND THAT HASN'T
WORKED FOR THEM.
>> Jon: THEIR STRATEGY HAS BEEN
TO PAINT SNP AS VERY NAIVE,
THAT YOU WILL NEVER BE ABLE
TO SURVIVE WITHOUT US.
YOU WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO
DELIVER ON THE PROMISES THAT
YOU HAVE MADE.
WHAT HAS BEEN FROM THE
ELECTION UNTIL NOW, WHAT HAS
BEEN THE MOST CHALLENGING
PART OF DELIVERING ON THOSE
PROMISES AND WHAT HAS BEEN
THE PART THAT HAS GONE AS
SMOOTHLY AS YOU WOULD LIKE.
>> IT'S ONLY A FEW WE CANS FROM
THE ELECTION, ONE OF THE THINGS
WE DIDN'T EXPECT, NOBODY ACROSS
THE U.K. DID EXPECT EXPECTE
DAVID CAMERON TO HAVE A
MAJORITY.
WE THOUGHT THERE WOULD BE A
HOME PARLIAMENT WHERE THE
SNP MIGHT HOLD THE BALANCE,
DAVID CAMERON'S GOT A MAJORITY,
THAT'S GOING TO  BE MORE
DIFFICULT TO WIN REAL PROGRESS,
BUT WE HAVE A CLEVER, TALENTED
BUNCH OF MPs THAT WILL MAKE
SCOTLAND'S VOICE HEARD AND
WE-- YOU KNOW, THE SNP WITH
THE GOVERNMENT IN SCOTLAND
AND THE DEVOLVED PARLIAMENT,
WE'VE BEEN THE GOVERNMENT FOR
EIGHT YEARS, AND WE'VE KEPT MOST
OF OUR PROMISES, DONE REALLY
GOOD THINGS FOR SCOTLAND.
AND IN EACH ELECTION, WE SEEM
TO GET MORE POPULAR.
SO WE KEEP TRYING TO DO OUR
BEST FOR SCOTLAND, AND HOPEFULLY
THE PEOPLE OF SCOTLAND WILL KEEP
VOTING FOR US.
>> Jon: IF THE DREAM COMES TO
PASS FOR YOU, AND --
>> THIS IS THE DREAM, JON.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: MAY I SAY SOMETHING
TO YOU AN I MEAN THIS FROM
THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART.
DREAM BIGGER.
>> YOU'RE SO HUMBLE.
>> Jon: WHEN YOU DID BACK TO
SCOTLAND, I DON'T EVEN THINK
IT'S AVAILABLE THERE.
>> IT'S ABOUT 4:00 IN THE
MORNING.
>> Jon: I KNOW THAT, I HAVE
MY CLOCKS HERE ALL SET FOR
SCOTISH TIME.
>> BUT YOU CAN EXPECT A SURGE
OF VIEWERS IN SCOTLAND AND THE
U.K., WITH ALL ALL MY POLITICAL
OPPONENTS.
>> Jon: THEY'RE GOING TO BE
TRYING TO FIND --
>> LOOKING FOR WAYS TO HUMILIATE
ME.
>> Jon: THIS IS EXCITING.
OH, YEAH, WELL, YOU'RE
GOING DOWN.
I GOT NOTHING.
BUT IT IS, I FIND IT
INTERESTING, IF THE DREAM
LIVES, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE HAVE
TO BECOME ACCUSTOMED TO THIS
IDEA THAT THEY STILL,
SCOTLAND GETS MORE MONEY,
DOESN'T IT, FROM ENGLAND,
FROM WESTMINSTER.
>> YOU KNOW, THE U.K. LIKE
AMERICA WAS IN DEFICIT SO WE
SPEND MORE THAN WE BRING IN
IN TAXES. SCOTLAND IS IN
THE SAME POSITION, BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S SUBSIDIZED
BY WESTMINSTER.
EVERY SINGLE YEAR, FOR
ABOUT 30 YEARS NOW, WE IN
SCOTLAND HAVE GENERATED MORE
TAX PER HEAD OF POPULATION THAN
THE U.K. BECAUSE WE'VE GOT A
STRONG PRODUCTIVE ECONOMY.
WE WORK PRETTY HARD.
>> Jon: 1.9% TO, I BELIEVE,
.9%.
>> WE'RE NOT SUBSIDIZED.
WE'RE MORE THAN CAPABLE OF
STANDING ON OUR OWN.
>> Jon: DO YOU LIKE THE
STATS.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA IF THEY
ARE TRUE, I THINK YOU JUST
MADE THEM UP.
YOU COULD BE A POLITICIAN.
>> Jon: LET ME TELL YOU THIS,
I BELIEVE WE MADE THEM UP.
>> YOU WOULD BE A REALLY
GREAT POLITICIAN.
>> Jon: THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
I APPRECIATE THAT.
IF YOU WERE TO GET THE
DREAM-- DO STILL DREAM OF
THAT SELF-DETERMINATION,
WOULD YOU STILL BE A PART OF
U.K., A PART OF THE EUROPEAN
UNION WHAT WOULD YOU WANT TO
DO.
>> YES TO BE PART OF THE
EUROPEAN UNION.
ONE OF THE REALLY WORRYING
THINGS ABOUT DAVID CAMERON
MIGHT BE ABOUT TO TAKE THE
U.K. OUT OF THE EUROPEAN
UNION.
THAT WOULD BE DEVASTATING
FOR SCOTLAND AND THE U.K.
SO HE WITH WANT TO BE PART
OF THE EUROPEAN UNION.
AND IF SCOTLAND BECAME
INDEPENDENT WE WOULDN'T BE
PART OF THE UNITED KINGDOM
ANY MORE, BUT WE WOULD STILL
BE PART OF THE BRITISH
AISLES.
SO SCOTLAND, WALES, ENGLAND,
NORTHERN ISLAND, A FAMILY OF
NATIONS AND WE CAN BE A
FAMILY OF NATIONS EVEN IF
SCOTLAND IS INDEPENDENT.
YOU KNOW MY GRANDMOTHER WAS
ENGLISH, MANY PEOPLE IN
SCOTLAND HAVE FAMILY IN
ENGLAND.
LOTS OF PEOPLE IN ENGLAND HAVE
FAMILY IN SCOTLAND.
WE'VE GOT REALLY STRONG
LINKS.
WE'VE GOT SHARED HISTORY.
THOSE LINKS WILL NEVER BE
BROKEN.
WE JUST WANT TO STAND ON OUR
OWN TWO FEET AND MAKE
OUR OWN DECISIONS.
>> Jon: WE FEEL THAT WAY
HERE ABOUT NEW JERSEY AND
WHERE WE'RE-- WE HAVE A LOT
OF BLOOD TIES BUT THE TRUTH
IS, IF WE LOST THEM -- MEH.
>> I THINK IT'S A SHAME.
>> Jon: IT IS A BIT OF A
SHAME.
ARE YOU GOING TO GO TO D.C.
AND TALK TO OUR POLITICIANS,
WHAT IS YOUR-- TO TALK ABOUT
HOW AUSTERITY DEVASTATES THE
COUNTRY, HOW IT IS A
DIFFICULT POLICY, HOW IT IS
ONE THAT IS NOT THE RIGHT
WAY OUT.
ENGLAND HAS SUFFERED AND
AUSTERITY.
THE THING THAT STRUCK ME AS
THE MOST UNUSUAL ABOUT THIS
ELECTION WAS AUSTERITY
POLICIES SEEM VERY UNPOPULAR
AND YET CAMERON AND THE TORYS
WON.
>> THAT'S BECAUSE ED
MILLIBAND AND LABOUR DIDN'T
STAND UP AND GIVE AN
ALTERNATIVE.
THEY PROMISED MORE OF THE
SAME, MORE OR LESS.
AND PEOPLE WANTED AN ALTERNATIVE
TO THAT.
>> Jon: DOW REMEMBER, IN THE
ELECTION WHERE AL GORE LOST
TO GEORGE W. BUSH, OR THEY
TIED, NOT THAT IT HAD
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE WORLD.
>> NOT VERY MANY.
>> Jon: BUT RALPH NADER WAS
THE SPOILER, AND EVERYBODY
WAS MAD AT RALPH NADER, ARE
YOU GUYS IN THE SPOILER
POSITION, COULD CAMERON HAVE
GOTTEN THAT MAJORITY.
>> THERE WERE NO HANGING
CHADS IN THE U.K. GENERAL
ELECTION.
EVEN IF LABOUR HAD WON EVERY
SINGLE SEAT IN SCOTLAND, IF
THE SNP HAD TAKEN NO SEATS,
THE TORIES WOULD STILL HAVE
WON.
THE TORIES WON IN ENGLAND.
ED MILLIBAND WASN'T ABLE TO
BEAT THE CONSERVATIVES IN
ENGLAND.
>> Jon: THE BACON SANDWICH, WHAT
HAPPENED?
>> THE BACON SANDWICH I DON'T
THINK HELPED, TO BE HONEST.
>> Jon: IT REALLY DIDN'T
HELP, THE BACON SANDWICH.
>> I DON'T THINK IT WAS THE
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM.
CERTAINLY IT DIDN'T HELP
THINGS.
>> Jon: I AM SO PLEASED TO MEET
YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS ON
BEING THE FIRST MINISTER OF
SCOTLAND --  YOU THE FIRST WOMAN
TO BE FIRST MINSTER OF SCOTLAND?
>> YES.
>> Jon: CONGRATULATIONS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: THE FIRST MINISTER
OF SCOTLAND.
WE WISH YOU WELL AND IF YOU
EVER ARE THINKING ABOUT
TRYING TO UNLOAD SOME OF
THAT SWEET, SWEET, NORTH
ATLANTIC TEA, YOU ALWAYS
HAVE A FRIEND IN AMERICA.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
(APPLAUSE)